I am really…
What? I really like you.
-Oh, girl, this is fancy!
-Look at this.
We fit right in here.
Good morning.
-Hey, girl!
-Morning.
My name is Liz Brewer,
but you will address me
as Ms Brewer.
For some reason,
Netflix feel
that you two need
a little bit of help
with your etiquette
and social behaviour,
so I've got to choose,
between you two,
the diamond.
Well…
-Don't gotta look too far.
-A challenge, I know.
It won't be a challenge.
I'm very easy, sis, OK?
I'm sorry, Ms Brewer.
…Briton to see it
in decades.
Benedict, dear,
you alarm our guests.
Here we are
at the dining table.
Vivienne, how would you
eat your sausage roll?
Oh…
I mean, if I was at home…
Oh, it's gone down me tits.
Normally, it is served hot.
Pretend it's hot.
Oh, fuck!
-Yeah, right. OK.
-That's hot.
It's oozing. It's drizzling.
Oh, my God!
I'm so sorry.
No burping.
This is very
Liverpoolian behaviour.
You take the napkin
and you wrap it
around your sausage roll.
-Yeah.
-Right?
Protection
for your sausage roll.
-Total protection.
-What you're saying is…
Wrap your sausage before
you put it in your mouth.
Yeah, unless your sausage
is on Prep,
and then you don't need…
-Prep?
-Prep.
That would be for
our finishing school, Liz.
Just control yourself.
What are you going to say
to gracefully
leave the table?
-Yeah?
-Would you say… Hang on.
-I can't with my mouth full.
-No.
You eye someone across
the table and be like…
-No.
-OK, well, I'm out of ideas.
You look to the person
on you're right,
person on your left,
and you say,
"Will you excuse me?"
"I'm going to powder
my nose."
But if we'd gone halves
on the bag,
we'd go together,
wouldn't we?
Yeah.
So now, sip your wine.
That's right.
No, no, no, you don't go…
You only do that
if you're at a tasting.
So when you have
many loads to taste,
you always spit them out,
you don't swallow each one?
If you're at a tasting.
-Of loads, OK.
-You know why?
-Yeah?
-You get drunk.
Or something else.
What's the something else?
-Liz…
-Syphilis.
-Can I offer you a…
-Certainly not.
I think Liz set us up
to fail there.
I mean, is there
a glamorous way
to eat a fucking
sausage roll?
We're stood here
with lip gloss on.
I look like I've been
noshing someone off
who had psoriasis
on their knob.
It's just not
a good look, is it?
Truly to admire a woman,
to delight in her beauty,
so much that all
your defences crumble,
that you would willingly
take on any pain,
any burden for her…
-OK, well, I want--
-Put your legs down, please!
And I can see right
the way up your skirt.
-OK.
-Cover your minge.
This furniture is priceless.
I think I've just trod
dog shit into the carpet.
So now, girls, I'm going
to teach you elocution.
Electrocution?
No, not electrocution.
Elocution
and why is important.
So we're going to have
a little bit of a test here.
This is a very
phallic symbol.
Now, listen, girls,
you've got to concentrate.
The Vivienne.
Oh, you want me to read it?
-Yes, I want you to read it.
-OK.
I'm not just sitting here
with a poker…
Poke her?
I don't even know her.
The rain in Spain
falls mainly down the drain.
Do you want me
to say it like you?
Yes.
The rain in Spain falls
mainly down the drain.
Absolutely fantastic.
Don't get me wrong,
I love regional accents,
but Scousers normally
swallow their vowels.
She's really good
at swallowing.
Yeah, exactly.
Now, Monét,
let's have your rain, so…
Sure, sure.
-The rain in…
-Rain.
…rain in Spain falls mainly
down the drain.
You sound like
Dick Van Dyke.
-That's pretty good.
-Thanks a lot, I know.
No, you don't know.
I'm teaching you.
I'll tell you
whether it's good or not.
I think Liz is absolutely
furious with us.
I feel bad
because I don't know
if Liz loves us
or absolutely hates us.
Exceptional posture.
Beautiful smiles.
Alright, enter!
You haven't closed the door.
Go out and do it again.
Enter!
Yeah, just as I thought.
-Thank you.
-That was cute, right?
No, it was appalling.
Vivienne, enter!
-Girl!
-Now?
-What, now?
-Yes, girl.
Oh, hang on.
She's terrible. I'm sorry.
Oh… interesting.
I don't want the booty
all over the place.
You want to become diamonds.
Right, shoulders back,
stomachs in.
So, I'm going
to actually help you
with some aids here.
That looks sadistic.
-It certainly is.
-This is getting kinky.
You'll have to kneel down.
This is getting
very kinky, Liz.
I feel like
I'm getting knighted.
-OK.
-Or noshing someone off.
-Either or. Oh!
-Whoops.
Oh, my God.
Girl!
-What are you doing?
-I'm…
Oh. Do you… Oh, sorry.
Oh, God.
My safe word is rutabaga.
-OK.
-It's a good one.
-The only one who might--
-Liz! What?
Liz, is that a harness?
Let's have a look,
see if this works.
Liz, I like you more
and more each day.
Oh, my God.
Liz is a kinky bitch!
That girl's sadistic.
Girl, what in
the Bonding season one
is going on here, Liz?
Go out and come in,
one at a time.
Who's coming first?
Oh, my nose!
Enter!
No!
No! I…
You've got to face me
all the time.
Go out and come in again.
In at the same time.
Enter!
Enough of the sashaying. OK.
That was, of course,
an absolute disaster.
A total disaster.
I feel great.
Flutter it so,
to draw his eyes
to your bosom.
There.
And remember to laugh
at his jokes.
Every man wishes to be
thought a sharp wit.
How would you
go about flirting
with a young gentleman?
That would require someone
being attracted to her.
Wow.
Now I'd like to see
how you flirt with a fan.
That's hardly flirting.
That's making me
jump out of my skin.
What about…?
Are you not going to do it?
That's the coke
from last night.
Listen, I love Liz,
but don't come and try
and teach two drag queens
how to clack a fucking fan.
Liz was very startled
by the clacking of the fan.
Could you imagine
if we killed Liz?
In this house? Girl.
So, what is your
great talent?
I now need a fan,
because I think
that is rather vulgar.
And not only do I think
it's rather vulgar,
but I don't think
you'll attract the young man
by doing that.
Oh, you don't know.
-You need to be subtle.
-Never say never.
This is probably
why I'm single,
so you have a valid point.
Girl, when I put
that fist in my mouth,
I think Liz
got a little chub.
She was like,
"Oh! Ho-ho-ho!"
You welcome.
Monét, can I ask you?
Please keep
your knees together.
-It's really hard for me.
-I know. Well…
-Old tricks die hard.
-Alright, girls,
I'm now going
to put you to the test.
We have an eligible bachelor
in the next room.
You're going to show him
the type of person
that you are.
Well, let's go bag a man.
The Dowager
Viscountess Bridgerton
and Miss Eloise Bridgerton.
Presenting The Vivienne.
Hello.
Presenting Monét X Change.
I'm sorry about that.
I just finished taking
a shit on the toilet.
-Yeah.
-Wow.
I'm just gonna put my
napkin in the correct place.
-Wow.
-This is where mine goes.
You both seem very proper.
So, Bas, what's
your favourite kind of date?
I kind of like outside,
field, footie, or…
Ooh, in a field? Oh, my God.
Excuse me.
Can I ask, what are your
yeses and noes on dates?
Oh, my yeses and noes.
OK, so some my yeses are:
I like to walk…
-OK.
-I like to gag.
-OK. Alright.
-I like to choke.
I want you to park
that little dangly thing
that swings in of my throat.
Whoa.
You know that's what…
-But we can talk about that.
-OK.
Wow.
This is very Get Out.
I don't like you stirring
that tea like that.
So, the age-old question:
cream or jam first?
-Definitely cream first.
-Smashing.
Are you a cream first
type of girl?
Oh, I always cream first.
Every time.
I've tried it
the other way around,
it just doesn't work
the same.
OK.
Shall I serve you some tea?
Please, yeah.
Would you like some milk,
my love?
-Yes, please.
-How would you like it?
Thick, creamy?
Thick is fine.
Take a… Oh.
Thank you very much.
So common.
It's hot. Be careful, dear.
I don't want you
to burn yourself.
Here you go, my darling.
-OK.
-You take a little bite.
Please say, "Vivienne,
I really enjoyed that."
How were those blueberries?
Are they mushy?
Or are they…
hard?
-I really enjoyed that.
-Yeah? You want some more?
No, no, I'm grand.
Say, "Please, Vivienne,
can I have some more?"
Want to taste
this chocolate cake?
See that, Vivienne?
He wants my cake.
Oh, wow.
I am really…
What? I really like you.
I like you too.
-I like really like you.
-Yeah.
I just wanted to show you
how strong my feet are.
They look like very
powerful feet, honestly.
Is that a read?
Ladies, it's been really
nice meeting both of yous.
Sure.
And I'll be in touch
with your teacher
as to my final choice.
-Yeah.
-OK.
That's cool.
-Thank you.
-Thank you very much.
Go ahead, take this
with you when you go, too.
-Go ahead.
-Oh, OK.
-Alright.
-Take that with you.
-That went well.
-That was great.
I mean, I don't know.
It is what it is.
I ain't sweatin' it.
I got a fucking man at home.
I don't even need this.
Our little bachelor
was lovely.
-Wasn't he?
-Oh, girl.
I think we scared the shit
straight out
of his arse today.
Hello, Liz. How are you?
OK.
To say I was disappointed
is an underestimate
of really how I'm feeling.
It would appear
that you disregarded
nearly everything
that I taught you.
I disagree.
Oh, really? What would
you disagree with?
-We were graceful.
-Leg on table?
It's usually
behind her head,
so you were lucky
it went on the table.
So what I've decided
is actually to give you both
a certificate…
on the condition
that you actually do
think about
what I've taught you today
and try and become
that person
that I see within you both.
And having given it
a great deal of thought,
and spoken to Bas,
I have decided
the winner will be…
The Vivienne.
-Her?!
-Motherfucker.
-I'm the lady, love.
-Liz, I can't…
Why?! Why not me, Liz?
-Go ahead.
-I was honoured.
I mean, we all saw it
coming, didn't we?
Bye, bitch.
I didn't wanna win anyway.
I don't wanna date him.
Like, are you serious?
I didn't wanna date him.
I didn't wanna…